ha herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute ich stehe zusammen
mit oskar und nicht nur mit oscar
sondern unter uns haben wir diese
wunderbare asia track trace von lego wir
machen nämlich heute drei teams
gegeneinander
eine krasse als die anderen gerade schon
mal reingeschaut ist echt derzeit steht
hier oben auf werbevideo weißen
kooperation ist aber ich kann nicht so
viel sagen dass du richtig richtig cool
und gespielt natürlich auch unser spiel
machen ja nicht einfach nur die changes
nein wir haben einen wetteinsatz und
zwar ist der wetteinsatz dass wir vom
jeweils anderen einteiliges foto vom
handy aussuchen dürfen und es in die
öffentliche instagram posten
[Musik]
so leute sie sind jetzt am schauplatz
der ersten challenge ihr seht es schon
fußball mit dem race am main razer hat
eine gelb schwarze fahne verpasst
bekommen damit sie besser unterscheiden
können und ja wir spielen darum wer als
erstes drei tore hat der kriegt dann den
einen challenge punkt das war nicht
alles los geht's du willst du ja das
können und inszenieren
[Applaus]
mehr
was ich habe nichts gemacht ist das denn
jetzt werden wir ihnen auch warum geht
er weiter ja ich habe keine chance
nummer ist man lieber nicht traurig nein
das müssen die nächsten zwei vielleicht
ich bin jetzt nicht bei der outdoor
channel bleibt dran
[Musik]
[Applaus]
leute wir sind dem autor parcours
angekommen es ist ziemlich krass wir
haben unterschiedliche hindernisse zum
beispiel müssen wir einmal durch blätter
über stärke und das wichtigste ist ich
muss dieses mal gewinnen weil auch sky
bleibt eben gewonnen das heißt wenn ich
jetzt nicht gewinnen habe ich direkt
verloren in meinem eigenen video und das
geht nicht
das will ich sagen du fängst an weil es
umso spannender wenn ich gleich die
zweite runde mache viel erfolg ich bin
werde dich zu vernichten
nicht irgendeine emotionen mein gesicht
nicht gewinnen werde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer ist denn hier geht durch stock und
stein wieder gleich durch doch jetzt ist
ihr sport maxx 3d effekt perfekter start
ist besser du siehst du das liest hier
die kurven gegeben
so bekommt der ware der wahre test
beziehen
ja sie ist das ist ganz schrecklich und
versuchen die seite ein bisschen
verweilen und das die entscheidende
kurve und am3 sekunden letzter roman
dort leute nicht mehr zurückgekommen
nein eigentlich herzlich dankeschön an
mein herz ist so aus was man knapp als
ich dachte
unglaublich und leute schaffen knapp in
die kommentare
[Musik]
leute die alles entscheidende letzte
challenge es wird richtig richtig
schwierig das jetzt ein
geschicklichkeitsspiel wir haben hier
unten diesen bürger für den kubus
und dem muss man mit dem razer durch
diesen parcours wir führen die gelb
schwarz gestrichelten linien sind
checkpoints und ganz wichtig man darf
nicht mit dem würfel über die grüne
linie kommt wenn man das macht kommt man
zurück ich würde schon zurückgesandt ja
wir schauen wer weniger fehler macht und
der gewinner wird mit ehre
[Musik]
da würde ich sagen
gut eingelebt verdammen vor wir gerade
sind nur computer fire
[Musik]
er gleicht der apple-weg fall ohne
einmal wirklich grüne linie bekommen
letzter check point abgehakt jetzt noch
gerade augen
[Applaus]
ich meine ich hoffe natürlich dass es
nicht überbieten kannst aber welche
erklärte spitz perfekt ausgelegt auf
alles ist perfekt
alter
[Musik]
freuen
schon jetzt die letzten meter
valentin was machen wir klar dass ich
würde sagen die echte männer und zwar
machen wir folgendes sie schnappen uns
beide wieder unseren racer und fahren
gemeinsam ohne würfel durch einen
parcours gustav diesmal der racer nicht
über die grüne linie
das heißt ja nicht raus hast du verloren
ich bin ich bin richtig richtig gespannt
jetzt offen hätte wären wir aber von ihr
weg zu ziehen
in der offensive das glück danke die
haben wirklich gut gemacht was ein guter
gegner
ich hätte bis zum schluss alles gedacht
dass du gewinnst irgendwie so haben im
verlauf des jahres wahrscheinlich noch
irgendwas also irgendwie ich habe so
etwas im hinterkopf bestrafung oder so
müssen wir vielleicht mal ein handy
geben das tun wir vielleicht mal ein
handy geben außerdem muss nicht so sein
ich nach kurzer war seine fotos auf
sowas haben wir das nicht er musste
gleich meine story post oder das was ich
brauche das nicht ich mache mir grosse
ich wollte da nicht so heiß kann gem
so habe ich es auch solche irgendwie
einen scherz bibliotheken von wegen und
in die story aber ein guter verlierer
wirklich hat sehr viel spaß macht an
dieser stelle auch noch mal großes
dankeschön an lego dass wir diesen
fetten oder diese betten faktors
überhaupt erstmal fahren durften
versorgt alle infos zum racer finden in
der beschreibung links kann natürlich
auch habe ich sagen das war's von heute
das gerne like damit es euch gefallen
hat wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder und bis dahin